-Hi, Paula!
-Hello, hello!
-You look wonderful!
-Thank you so much.
I Kondo'd my closet so hard,
I had to go get an outfit.
-Oh, wow!
[ Laughter ]
-Because all I had left
was like a bra and sweatpants
that I only wear
when I have the flu.
-Oh, gotcha.
[ Laughter ]
-So, I got a little suit.
-That's the danger.
The danger of Kondo'ing.
You over-Kondo'd.
-Hold on.
Ahh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You're looking at my butt
right now.
[ Laughter ]
Hi.
-I have known you
for a very long time.
-So long.
-And I met you as a writer
at "SNL,"
and everyone who ever worked
in a writer's room with you
knew you to be
the funniest person on Earth.
And now it's really exciting,
because you're acting
a lot more now,
and the world is seeing
how funny you are.
-I am. I'm aging into these
older-lady characters.
I was born at 50.
I was born a matron.
But I always wore
the gray spray in my hair
and played the Mother Superior
in 8th grade
in "Sound of Music,"
and now I'm actually --
of an approximate age --
I'm nearing an approximate age
where I can play a lady,
say, in her 50s.
[ Laughter ]
-That's wonderful.
And the world is so happy
to have it.
And now you've created
so many characters --
too many to list --
for wonderful actors at "SNL"
over the years.
You have a new character.
-I have a new character.
-For yourself, now,
which is really exciting.
-That I just created just to
soothe myself and my friends.
It's just kind of
not fully flushed out yet,
but I was gonna try it out
on you.
-Great.
-It's -- It got inspired
when I was drinking some tea,
some green tea,
and I found what was
on the box so comforting.
Come over here, Seth.
-Okay. Come sit next you?
-The world is just such a scary
place now, so I just --
-Okay.
-I want you to feel --
-And what's the name
of your character?
-My character's name
is Nana Teabags.
-Okay, gotcha.
[ Laughter ]
-So, just come over here
with me.
-Okay.
-And just really
park your head on my bosom.
Just go --
-Okay. Like that?
Okay.
-Just right in the bike rack.
[ Laughter ]
Now just close your eyes.
-Okay. The bike rack?
-And I'm just gonna
read about tea.
You ready?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Through the screened
front door,
zingy lemongrass
and spritely spearmint
coax contemplative pan-fired
green teas to come play.
[ Laughter ]
Calmly,
lemon verbena opens the door
and invites them all
to a cup of tea.
[ Laughter ]
Now, wait.
There's a little bit more.
-Oh, okay.
[ Laughter ]
-Giggling -- Giggling notes
of curious chai tea
peek mischievously
from behind a painted screen.
They summon us
and gently suggest
that we join their spicy hang
and leave our pantaloons
at the door.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You have such --
-Go back and sit there,
'cause I'm starting
to get straight.
[ Laughter ]
-You have such --
-My 10% went to 12%.
-[ Cheers ]
-You're up to 12?
That's a new record.
-I'm up to 12
when I'm sitting with you.
You're foxy.
-Thank you.
Your diction is such
that you were just, like,
blowing those words
across the top of my hair.
-Yeah.
Just very Sally Kellerman.
-Yes.
-Blue-cheese dressings.
[ Laughter ]
-You had another incredible
performance this year,
and even Jesse Eisenberg,
a previous guest,
was shouting you out.
An episode of "Documentary Now,"
you played --
You basically channeled
Elaine Stritch.
-I channeled her.
I did not do
a real impression of her,
because no one can be
Elaine Stritch.
-You grabbed her spirit.
-Yes.
-Because there was this famous
moment in this documentary
about the "Company"
cast recording
where she was having issues
singing her song,
"Ladies Who Lunch."
-Yes.
-You, in this episode,
were singing a song,
"I Gotta Go,"
also having difficulties.
Let's take a look at a clip
real fast.
-"I Gotta Go,"
take 11.
-Benedict, just so we're clear,
earlier, many times I mentioned
I had an eye-doctor appointment
to get my eyes scraped,
and I have already
taken the medication,
and it's ripping
through my system.
So we need
to be brisk with this.
Let's just do it.
♪♪ And I gotta go ♪♪
♪♪ I should do better
or different than this ♪♪
No [bleep] kidding.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It was so --
so joyous to watch you.
I hope you enjoyed doing this.
-It was so beyond --
I'm such a theater nerd.
I got my degree in theater
in college.
I always did theater,
and it was --
And I stage-managed "Company"
when I was young.
And my mom actually played
that Elaine Stritch role.
She hadn't done theater
since high school, and she said,
"I turned 40, and I'm gonna
get my license finally --
driver's license --
and I'm gonna be in a show."
And she played --
She sang "Ladies Who Lunch."
So it was, like,
a perfect little
beautiful thing,
but we kept laughing
because we loved
doing it so much,
and learning all the music
that we kept, like --
We finished, and they're like,
"Great, we're wrapped,"
and we're like,
"Can't we go to Seattle in a van
and do this at local theaters?"
[ Laughter ]